the drama keeps coming today absolutely
uh we are standun while Faby was being
interviewed because remarkably King and
Rook versus King and Bishop The Rook
loses why does The Rook lose because the
clock look at the clock three three two
and make a move but he doesn't in time
and he got flagged exactly you lose on
time and there and did an realize it
immediately I don't think so no wasn't
even looking he was he was sure he was
going to make it in time and
he there you see it and he doesn't even
no this yet yet
yet but he is about to and it's going to
be a beautiful Revelation by the way how
does Anish giri
win dying unbelievable